our next speaker
one time performed at an amateur comedy
night at the madison comedy club
everyone please welcome tom
so hi everyone uh my name is tom blitz i
hope everyone is a football fan because
this is obviously our second football
presentation
uh so i'm gonna be talking about player
movement in the nfl and and how it's
being used across sports
so
what we use like like a new data source
that we have
at the nfl and again across all sports
is called
uh next-gen tracking data shout out mic
band for that but it's it's location
data it's xy coordinates it's speed
acceleration of all the players
throughout the play
again it's it's
new improving it's relatively
like recent that we had this data it's
only 2018 to present
and it's it's not just used in the nfl
it's used across all leagues and so
on the bottom here we have an animation
um essentially what you see is each dot
there represents a player throughout a
play in for an nfl game and
you can see how the players are moving
throughout the play and uh
understand that they uh like
see the xy coordinates see how fast
they're going see how much they're
accelerating it's a lot more information
than we had previously
so
yeah as i was just saying traditionally
what we would have is just outcomes of
plays and for those of you watch
football you would know uh it's a very
start and stop game you'll you'll start
um
like at a certain state and like like we
have information like okay you know the
score you know the down you know the
distance you know where they are on the
field
and then the next information you get is
once the play is over so
what this tracking data is is now we
have everything that occurred within the
play and instead of just knowing okay
this play was a touchdown we know oh
this receiver ran this route to get open
for a touchdown
um it's a lot uh like we've only had it
recently as i said on the previous slide
it's just it's a lot more data so before
it's about 150 rows per game and now
we're dealing with millions of rows per
game which
uh as as everyone here is a data
scientist they should know like more
data is a good thing
so it's used across a bunch of different
sports for a bunch of different reasons
used for player evaluation for example
um you can figure out how fast the
player is moving throughout a game you
can figure out
like the whether the movement is causing
some other thing on the opposing team
you can dig a lot deeper in that
coaching strategy of course too
i read a paper recently and it was on
essentially using a deep learning model
they were able to mimic the
this was in soccer they were able to
mimic what the opponent would do based
on what like the positioning of their
players so you can use that to sort of
figure out um strategy and figure out
what
would make sense and what
how you could possibly use the the the
your players to get a certain response
from the opponent
and then finally player conditioning and
health i think that might be the obvious
one in the sense that obviously like
you're thinking of speed you're thinking
of acceleration
you're thinking of you you can do a lot
in in terms of injury recovery in terms
of measuring how
fast a player has been and whether
they're
increasing in speed whether they're
being overworked whether they're not
working enough
there's a lot we can do with this data
and
uh teams and and and
people are everywhere are working with
it but i think we're just at the tip of
the iceberg of everything we can do
so what do we do specifically at the nfl
league office so
um
at the nfl league office we're not
necessarily interested in any particular
team winning but we're more interested
in games being competitive games being
exciting um so i mean yeah despite
despite others despite some fans maybe
disagreeing with that but uh so we want
like excited exciting games competitive
games we want games where
that are well officiated we want games
with with fast pace of play we don't
want a bunch of stoppages so
we don't want
long breaks where nothing is happening
and obviously we want as few we don't
want to see players get injured um
that's you want to see our top players
able to play and it's it's just bad for
the game when players are getting
injured and again
we're we're the league office so we
can't tell a team oh you should run this
play because it'll help you with
injuries or oh you should run this play
because you'll be able to score more and
it'll be more competitive like the teams
themselves make those decisions so our
avenues of influence are maybe like to
try to make the games as competitive
well officiated
increase health and safety
it's not necessarily controlling what
the teams would do but it's maybe other
factors such as rule changes
as well as the team schedules which and
which is sort of determined by the clubs
broadcast theirs and ultimately um the
nfl
so with all that um i'm going to give a
sort of a toy example of how we can use
the the tracking data combine that kind
of with our goals and um
like show
what what we can do uh before so
for for this toy example we're going to
look at
surface as well at which is grass field
turf um sort of the the the what the the
game is being played on
as well as the play clock and the play
clock is for those of you don't follow
football essentially
if there's a timer after one play ends
before the next place has to start or
else you're going to get penalized so
those are the two things i'm going to
analyze
here
again i'm going to use the ngs tracking
data which i just described and my
methodology for for this um simple
example i'm just going to look at
regression analysis
all right so
i've talked a lot about player movement
i mean the talk is about player movement
but and player performance but it's a
very hard thing to define in in the
sense that i mean what is what is player
performance is it how fast you're going
is it how fast you're going at the end
of the game once you're tired is it
um like there's a bunch of different
ways to define like performance
athleticism
um
it's not a it's not a simple
term it's sort of a vague term so
you want to think about a way to define
it and in football it's about it's more
complicated it's about as complicated as
you can get in the sense that a lot of
the movement is dictated by how other
players are moving and a lot of the
movement is you're moving in you're
trying to push somebody over you're
moving into somebody so in that sense a
lot of the the movement is sort of
dissipated and it's not easily
measurable in the set like with with xy
coordinates
um
because the
if if two like they're not going to move
very much when two players are in
contact it's unclear whether the the
player is unable to move because they're
not
trying to move or if they're being
blocked it gets very confusing really
quickly and i mean as you can see this
picture like this is what a game might
look like you have
players blocking each other pushing into
each other there isn't really any clear
place where you might have a player
sprinting or or some way where you can
easily measure their ability and in the
sense that
like we if we were to use this we would
be missing data we'd be missing
information on what the player could do
um as opposed to what they did do
so
um the the what we decided to do here is
look at sort of one
situation within a game and it
it it's not super common in the sense
that we we have
um like
a bunch of games and
this occurs but there's this route in
the nfl called a go route and that a
route meaning what the receiver will do
in order to try to get open to try to
catch the pass
in this case the receivers will sprint
downfield as fast as possible
and
what what we kind of realized was one of
the rare places where there isn't quite
this issue in terms of players running
into each other um is on this go route
and again if we were to do another route
if we were to do like uh like receivers
running like a curved route or some or a
route with a cut in it that also be
difficult because
again they might not be running their
full speed because they're anticipating
some sort of curve or
some sort of other quick movement
so that's why we're gonna have to focus
on that um right here on the bottom left
we have an illustration i think that's
from madden for those of you who play
madden but it's uh what what the rap
what it looks like all the players are
kind of running forward and here on the
right
this is a
play from the 2020 season if you look at
the four players on the in white on the
denver broncos in the bottom section
those are those players are running a
streak route and you can see they just
are sprinting for they're just sprinting
forward
and again opposed to all the the
blockers and the quarterback and
everyone else who's
kind of their movement is very much
tailored by everything else going on
so within this framework
uh what we decided to do is look at max
sustained speed and the reason we want
to use sustained speed as opposed to
just the straight max is we don't want
to be susceptible to
um an outlier that
sort of deters the the
like pulls the data to a certain place
that it's not so we're looking over our
0.5 second interval their max sustained
speed um we're also filtering for some
other things such as making sure the the
quarterback had enough time like the
quarterback doesn't throw the ball
immediately or gets sacked immediately
um
so that way we're not over counting
anything and we also want to wait we
want to do it
we want to do it before the ball is
thrown just in in the sense that if
there's some sort of tackle or some
other sort of movement that might be
influencing this we want it to be
focused only on the part of the field
where the receivers are just running
so
again we're going to use max sustained
speed
on these routes and that's going to sort
of be our data set it's about 8 000 from
2018 to 2022
which so that's essentially 8 000 times
a receiver ran that streak route um
and and had ample time without the
quarterback being tackled early or
like the past being thrown early
so for example this play would have four
observations
so the the methodology here we're not
just going to use this uh like a
ordinary linear regression
we're going to use a mixed effects model
and in sports
i think mixed effects models are really
nice and really helpful
so
a fixed effect model that's something
that we're probably all used to if you
just in r if you just do lm you're going
to have a fixed effects model um and
obviously those work in a lot of cases
but in this situation what we want to do
is we want to
um
take the variable that we're interested
in in this case field surface or play
clock
see how that in addition to the effects
from the player
have an effect on on max sustained speed
and model and look at that effect so if
we were to model like players as fixed
effects because obviously the the
fastest player in the slowest players
can be a difference so we we don't want
the model to just pick up on the
difference between players if we're
going to model fixed effects we're going
to imagine players of fixed effects
we're going to add like 500 columns
which obviously for from a complexity
standpoint isn't really the way to do it
so the advantage of using a mixed model
and using a random effect for player id
is instead of adding one like 500
variables we're essentially adding the
same complexity as one fixed effect
variable
and allowing the uh like the values to
fluctuate so the fastest receiver and
the slowest receiver will have different
values for a given
player
but
we also aren't making it overly complex
we're sort of assuming that all the
players come from the same distribution
which is a good assumption in the sense
that it's not like one of the players is
like
a cheetah and one of the players is a
car one of the players is a human being
and one of the like like they're all the
same population and obviously they're
all nfl players so it's already athletic
very top players so
uh that that's the assumption we're
doing here and and again the variable of
interest will still be a fixed effect
but the player id um which will it would
be a random effect and we're going to
take essentially it's it the
the more observations we have the more
confident will be that this player is
far away from average but other we're
going to assume that the all the players
are from the same observation and
um that way we can we can add them and
not overfit the model
so to dig deeper into what these player
effects actually look like
here's an example of the top 15
in terms of the the player effects so
uh what you're seeing here on this chart
the y-axis is our receivers they're
players that that are in the data set
they're they're people that are
sprinting um these are these are the top
15. the x-axis is the change in max
sustained speed from an average receiver
so
for example um like prashad paraman he's
the fastest desean jackson's the second
fastest and if you take desean jackson
you compare them to an average receiver
doing in the exact same situation on the
same field doing the exact same thing
he's going to be about 1.4 miles per
hour faster
so this is what they this is what the
output looks like and again the
advantage is we can we can have these
differences but we're not over fitting
the model
and the standard deviation of the random
effects was just the way to think about
how important they are like if they're
if the top player and the bottom player
aren't that different the standard
deviation will be small but because they
are different it's it's
it's
it's not it's non-zero so it's about 0.7
and again these are all no for those of
you who fall football like a lot of
these names are known as these fast
speedy deep threat receivers so it makes
sense that we're seeing these names
all right so i'm going to first talk
about surfaces so
i'm going to go back
essentially we're taking the we're we're
fitting a a mixed effects model max
sustain speed is our y variable the
variable of interest which in the first
case will be surfaces is the x is that x
variable and then player id remains a
random effect so if we were to do this
and we were to analyze the coefficients
that we we get here so we're accounting
for player differences
um and we're just seeing how max
sustained speed is affected we get this
chart and
the y-axis here are different types of
surface different types of grass less
artificial turf um
the the top section there the first the
ones in the red box those are all types
of turf i don't expect anyone to know
the difference between them i don't know
the difference between them they're just
different um
turf like different slightly different
material from each other
so i decided to differentiate them um
the uh the
the then then like the x axis here
that's that's change in max sustained
speed from grass and grass is our
reference variable reference layer here
so as you can see shaw sports momentum
pro seems to have a big effect on the
biggest effect in a positive direction
in terms of change in max
speed from grass
and the the lowest is grass slash
baseball diamond and for those of you
who maybe watch football there was a
team the the oakland raiders who
had a stadium
in which
part of it
they shared with a baseball
uh team so
during some of the weeks of the season
there was a there was like an outfield
in the middle of the stadium or in the
middle of the field which you can see up
there
uh so
that is that that's what that is um
and again like
we're we're somewhat involved in in the
field surf like like in terms of field
surfaces and this is something that the
league can be involved in
um and then the other uh thing that we
have the other thing that i'm going to
talk about here is is play clock so
again play clock that's the amount of
time that you have to start the the to
take the snap before you would get
penalized
um
and that that's like a a player's tackle
the player goes out of bounds and then
you're able to then you have 40 seconds
before
the offense is penalized if they don't
snap the ball before then so there have
been suggestions to shorten this play
clock make it
um
less so that way maybe you're going to
see more plays it'll go faster
that that's definitely been something
that's been suggested so in a way a way
we can analyze this and again this is a
a simple example we're really only
looking at one component of player
performance here but a way to analyze
this would be if we look at the time
from the previous play and then we look
we look at how the max sustained speed
will change
um based on that we can see that there
is a positive effect in the sense that
if you have more time between the plays
the players are able to reach faster
speeds which intuitively makes a lot of
sense you're going to be less tired
you're going to be less exhausted you
didn't just
if you have more time to catch your
breath before you have to before play
restarts
uh again maybe you're seeing the the
y-axis
it it isn't that big of a difference
we're talking about about 0.4 miles per
hour uh but it's non-zero and maybe it
wouldn't be the like if somewhere to
propose this rule wouldn't change
everything but it is something that we
would want to take into account
so
in terms of rule changes obviously that
the nfl is involved in that process so
this is something that we can use and
bring to the table and
i mean this is kind of the case with a
lot of things but when it comes to the
rule changes maybe shorting the play
clock it'll you'll have less dead time
you'll have more time when the players
are actually playing but then you're
going to have other effects such as
perhaps maybe the players aren't able to
reach their peak performance as much and
again we want
the game the players to be the games to
be as competitive as possible we want to
see the the athletes doing everything
they can
all right so
again here are the results um looking at
the that in this example um surface
clearly had had an effect i mean we saw
uh like some with an effect of about 0.8
miles per hour and then we saw that
baseball field um around negative point
eight so there definitely is an effect
um
in terms of max speed reached which is
pretty intuitive it makes sense you're
you're probably able to run a little bit
faster depending on what surface how
that what material you're running
through play clock there there was a
smaller effect but but a non-zero effect
um and
again we
from from this analysis we would come
back and say you know maybe shortening
the play clock would help in in some
case in some ways but it wouldn't be uh
it wouldn't be the end there would be a
negative effect to it possibly
and yeah so that is my presentation
thank you all for listening
[Applause]
thank you